I've been a busy boy this summer and
I've read some great books and some
not-so-great books in this video I'm
going to talk about which ones which
before I go any further if you're
interested in full written reviews of
these books all just generally what I'm
reading at any given moment then I have
a Goodreads they'll be a link in the
description and there's also these Simon
Oxford's book club which is coming back
more about that at the end of the video
to begin with a book which I talked
about in the previous book video but
master algorithm by Pedro Dominguez now
I read the very start of this book when
I made that last video and I read this
on holiday and they couldn't even see
but it's a very very battered copy it
travelled quite away with me I think
depending on who you are this is either
a three-star book or a five-star book I
think if you're going into it like me is
someone with a lot of experience in
programming specifically if you're going
into it as someone who's sort of a
computer scientist in any way
it's a three-star book it's kind of a
frustrating read and I'll get to why
whereas I think if you're coming into
this with no expertise in programming or
computers really then you're going to
find this absolutely fascinating so what
about all that distinction um it's
because the book basically goes through
the ways in which machine learning works
right so there are different ways of
making a computer learn how to do a task
there are hours a figure in here which
actually summarizes it very very neatly
it's yeah I'll do a close-up on it
so the book basically puts across that
there are different camps of machine
learning
there's Symbolists and Bayesian 's and
connectionists and evolutionary's and
basically lots of different ways of
approaching the same problem using
different techniques and I think what I
grow out of it as a programmer was
basically that fact and a kind of basic
idea of how those things work but what
it lacked was the what I thought
necessary detail and and in particular
not having equations which I can
understand in a general book most people
are kind of intimidated by equations I
think Stephen Hawking was told that for
everyone and he put in a brief history
of time that the viewership would have
so he I think he put two and possibly
just one in so you know I can understand
why they haven't Pedro Dominguez hasn't
but he's effectively expressing in words
what you were put in an equation so I
could read in one line what he describes
in two or three pages
and it's just a bit frustrating to read
when you have that kind of training and
you're like that's like I know that you
can express this batter this is just
like fluff that set though the book
definitely did make me interested in
machine learning and I've got a few
ideas for videos actually I'd like to do
based on some of the techniques I
learned in this book why like in order
to do that I am now gonna have to go and
find specific papers and to the books
credit it does give it the back a list
of sort of recommended reading if you're
interested in the technical aspects this
at the end of the day is a primer it's
an introduction to the field it's not a
textbook or anything like that so you
know don't expect that I think if you
come into this expecting just to kind of
get a sense of what machine learning
means and how you can do it in different
ways and a postulated way that you know
you can connect those different ways
that's what the master algorithm is and
then also at the end of the part of
really fascinating chapter on how
machine learning could change the world
and how you know using it as a technique
could completely revolutionize for
example treating cancer that aspect of
it is fascinating so I would recommend
this to pretty much anyone with the
proviso and sort of the caveat that if
you are a scientist don't expect
equations don't expect the huge amount
DS out and expect to have to do extra
reading after this because you almost
certainly will find it interesting and
will want to and unfortunately will have
to next a much less satisfying book
Eureka by Andrew Gregory now I I find
Greek science fascinating I thought I
find sort of the history of science one
of the most interesting things about the
whole field and so I was given this book
and you know told it's basically an
overview of Greek science and I was
thinking fantastic you know you have the
philosophical arguments about how they
approach science how they approach the
world a kind of you know an interesting
look at some of the key individuals like
Pythagoras or Aristotle and you know it
had so much potential and it actually
failed to deliver as I say on my
Goodreads review this is basically a
list this book is just the list of in
this field this happened and this
happened and this happened then this
happened and I get the next kind of what
history is at its most basic form but
you're missing all the analysis that
comes on top of that you're missing like
characterization of the important people
and I know they lived a long time ago
difficult to know a huge amount about
them but they're there's so many more
interesting stories that I know having
only read a little bit about this field
before I was expecting this to be kind
of like it mean as a relatively thin
book I thought it would be a kind of
North mary jaunt we know what I mean it
was gonna be like a fun kind of
introduction leaning on a
characterization of the individuals and
sort of going going through the
chronology yes with this happened and
this happened and this happened but
giving some overarching themes of the
transition you know towards I'm sonic
more rational society and then you know
even touching on how that affected the
bobbin and how it also kind of faded
away up until the Renaissance and I just
felt like this book really didn't give
that I think to be honest the only kind
of person who might find this actually a
valuable read is someone who knows
absolutely nothing about Greek science
and as a kid but to be honest there's
not very much to talk about in this book
because I found very little but I liked
about it you know it was a bit of us it
was a bit of a struggle to get through
because it was just boring there are
better ones out there I'd give this one
a Miss next up my mandatory Warhammer
Book of the Year sort of video this is
the Magus by Dan Abnett and I absolutely
loved it dan Abner is by far and away my
favorite black library author I think
you know if you take him out the black
library he is just a great author
regardless of what he's writing about
and he's and he has you know he's listed
as a writing credit for examples of
guardians of the galaxy like he's
written well outside that the Warhammer
universe he's written Judge Dredd he's
written guardians there's a bunch of
other stuff which I can't remember us
top of my head and the stuff that he
writes in this book which is part of a
trilogy of trilogies except this is book
number four in the first trilogy so it's
two trilogies in a quadrilogy is it's
the best stuff the Platt library does
it's basically most of the books which
Games Workshop publish are about war
that's kind of it's got Warhammer you
know it's in the name this stuff is all
about the domestic side of things it's
about really rich setting that's been
built up over decades of other authors
and people playing the games and I mean
I've read about 10,000 pages of
Warhammer law and I feel like I've just
about scratched the surface and this is
the stuff that is sort of the richest
that gives you the best overview of
and I absolutely love with the
Inquisition books a super quick review
for those of you who are interested this
book is actually a novel which is
provoke half at the runtime
the paper page page count and the other
half is a series of short stories and
what this book does actually is it kind
of glues together the trilogy of
trilogies in a very neat way and it
actually has a reading order at the
start it says you know these are the
other books in the in the series you
should read this one then the first
short story the next one then that's
still a short story and then going all
the way through and then this is kind of
the linchpin in a way of a lot of the
series and I am very tempted to go back
and read the rest of them basically
because I enjoyed this one so much if
you like 40k absolutely read the
inquisition books so you can get to this
one next a book which I don't actually
have with me so it's gonna split up here
is Total Recall by Arnold Schwarzenegger
so I've been kind of fascinated by ala
Schwarzenegger for quite a while I think
as I said in my Goodreads review he kind
of represented this super saturated
super masculine Hollywood ideal when I
was a kid you know I was born just
before Terminator 2 came out and so for
all three the 90s he was this ultimate
action star and then he became the
Governor of California and then when I
became interested in in bodybuilding and
going to the gym he obviously like a
paradigm of that so he's kind of
followed me for several decades actually
with most of my life I've been aware of
him in different aspects so when I was
given that was given this book as a
present quite a while ago and I finally
got around to reading it it was actually
everything I hoped it would be it was a
very very good autobiography because he
was active in so many different sectors
during his life the book is kind of
split between bodybuilding and the movie
business and the governing business and
if you're interested in any of those
things you're gonna find this book
interesting because it's you know a
massive figure in any one of those
fields this is an important account but
I think what I got most of all from this
book was the attitude that he has to
everything in his life because he is a
phenomenally successful person he has
done stuff which I disagree with and you
know I wouldn't want to be him
necessarily but he has undoubtedly been
very successful at what he has turned
his attention to and a lot of that has
to do with his mindset which is
basically it's all about putting in the
effort it's all about the repetitions
that you do on
sighs or on a line or on a speech and
just basically be willing to try and
that was the the main takeaway from the
book and it's an attitude which I've
sort of taken from him before from
speech as I've seen I'll leave a link in
the description actually there's an
amazing speech of his rules of success
which kind of echo his conclusions in
his autobiography and you know it was
just a very motivational book if you
can't not read this book and then think
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna do stuff I
don't know III can if he can do all this
bar stuff I can do some of this too
I mean I don't think I'm ever gonna be
missed mr. Olympia but you know maybe no
I think I'm gonna be applying the
lessons of this book in other ways but
it was very motivational
I immediately lent it to a friend
actually because I was like you need to
read this so highly highly recommended
quite an easy read as well quite long
but nice easy holiday reading then
lastly and a book I have been so excited
to talk about is labelled savage by
Philip Pullman this book so for the five
people in the world who might not know
Philip Pullman wrote the trilogy called
His Dark Materials which is Northern
Lights or the Golden Compass
southern life and they have a spyglass
and they are like a monumental piece of
children's fiction they are so ambitious
so well written terribly adapted into
film but actually there is the BBC
series that's coming soon and a massive
part of my childhood I absolutely loved
those books I've read them twice all the
way through my dad has read them about
three times because when we first came
out I was at the age when my parents
would read Northern Lights to me the
first couple of chapters and eventually
I was like I just got a plough on and do
it myself
I'd bit in the bug but also my parents
had because they read some of the
chapters so it's just so I absolutely
love the world that he's created in
those books and this is the follow-up
it's actually a prequel it's a prequel
to the trilogy and it actually deals
with sort of a key character in it is
the baby
he becomes Lyra in His Dark Materials
one of the
the kind of the protagonist of the whole
arc and it's just just reading this book
it was like going back to being a kid
because the world that he's created you
just immediately fell back in love with
if you haven't read the book so the main
difference I mean there are lots of
subtle differences between
the world that Lyra lives in and our
world but the main difference is that
people have demons which is their soul
in animal form and so kids demons keep
changing but adults demons are set in a
particular form so the protagonist
Malcolm in this I think his mum's demon
is a badger for example and if you're
like a steeple jack or a carpenter there
were demons like a woodpecker and you
know it's the the form that your soul
takes in demon form says a lot about who
you are as a person and if that's just
one example of how the world is
different and just the way that he
writes in that world is masterful I
think Philip Pullman is one of my
absolute favorite authors I've had the
pleasure of meeting him actually I got
him to sign my copy of Northern Lights
which I'm a geek out every time I think
about it this book just felt like coming
back to that world but with differences
in tone I think I'm right in saying that
this book is not meant for children and
they start materials it's definitely a
children's trilogy but this has for
example a bunch of swearing in totally
there are a few things which a little
bit distinct I think from Northern
Lights and you know the other books and
so you know it's it's the same but
different
and I just yeah in case you can't tell I
absolutely loved reading this book if I
was to offer some criticism I'd say that
the beginning is perfect absolutely
perfect
and you can kind of divide the book into
two really I think actually is but it is
divided into two parts of I won't spoil
it but before a flood and after a flood
and I feel like before the flood is it's
flawless I genuinely wouldn't change a
single thing I felt like as the flood
half of the book went on it got more and
more abstract and I felt like it ended
very abruptly I felt like I was taken
out it was taking me out of the book a
little bit that there's a key sort of
couple of chapters towards the end where
everything does get very abstract
you know considering how grounded the
rest of the book is in reality and from
memory I am now going to go reread his
dart materials from memory the other
books are all very grounded in they
always have a sense of reality the stuff
at the end of this which wasn't
definitely stood out and yeah it took me
out of the book in have an unpleasant
way and it ends very abruptly really III
know that this is the first book of
three although I've heard rumors that
the second book is actually meant to be
after Lyra's Adventures and they start
materials so I'm a bit confused by that
but yeah they're not absolutely flawless
but pretty close to it I mean I think if
you enjoyed his dart materials you'd be
a fool to not read this and actually
there's one more thing take the dust
cover off look at how gorgeous
the book itself is like I'm going
gingerly open it you've got all the dust
on either side and then the quote from
Lord Asriel on the on the spine I even
like I physically love the book and I
loved the its contents and loved reading
it you'd be a fool not to not to read it
and if you haven't read it start
materials absolutely do that probably do
that first then leave this okay so those
the books which I have read over the
summer and now coming up oh it's a
really good book as has been requested
for so long I finally got myself a copy
of homo Deus which my girlfriend
immediately stole I've only just got it
back she left that bookmark in here she
oh my she didn't meet it halfway for you
I loved sapiens it was one my favorite
books of all time so I can't wait to dig
into this for those of you who aren't
aware there'll be a link in the
description I did a video review of
sapiens on its own because it's oh
another book which was requested several
times over and I am very very excited to
finally own because it was bought for me
as a birthday present the name of the
wind by Patrick Rothfuss I yeah that
I've heard so many good things about
this book so many friends have been
screaming at me to read it for years I
finally have it and I will be getting
onto this as probably my next fiction
book I tend to read one nonfiction and
one fiction so that's probably give me
the next fiction now that I finished
labelled Sauvage but most excitingly
most excitingly the book club is back
and we are reading a brief history of
time by Stephen Hawking now you may
remember that we said that we were going
to read this before that was me and my
friend Dan who were gonna
read this book and one of us didn't so
I'm reading stay from the book club in
about a month's time there will be a
video talking about just this book not
lots of them but just this one having a
deep dive or might think about it and I
would encourage you to read it to like I
said at the start of the video there is
a Goodreads group which is the book club
for this channel down there in the
description so you can join that anybody
can join it and get involved in the
discussion there and we'll all read this
book together there's like a thousand
people in that group so it's actually
quite it's quite a lot of us will all
read the book we'll report back in about
a month with what we relatively thought
I have before I have read this before I
gave a crackit reading this in primary
school which means that I probably
didn't understand about 90% of it and
it's such an iconic book that I've got
to give it a proper adult read so very
very excited about this one and very
excited to be reading something again
with you guys and you know actually
having a proper deep dive and hearing
your thoughts on the boat too so these
are the first three things which I'm
going to be reading there are a bunch
more things downstairs including books
which I've been sent and I feel terrible
for not reading but I've just been so
busy that I've done had a chance to read
but I've started reading every night
before bed my girlfriend and I now have
like a 15 minute timer we both read
before bed so hopefully I'll actually
start to churn through these relatively
quickly compared to I did this summer
have you read any of these books because
if so I would like to hear your thoughts
on them as well leave them down there in
the comments please oh you can't
recommend stuff to me I was gonna say
police don't beat your course you can
recommend the stuff to me to read as
well but be aware I've got an awful lot
of books to read as it is mostly I'm
interested to hear what you've been
reading especially if you've been
reading stuff that I've been reading so
we can compare notes so put those down
in the comments thank you very much for
watching this video I love to moods book
videos I just don't do them very
frequently because it takes a while to
read you know but if you enjoyed it do
pop it a like and share it if you
thought it was worth sharing because
that sort of says to me that I should do
more of them and yeah thank you again
for watching I'll see you the next one
[Music]
you
[Music]